est ce que tu veux bien regarder la
caméra y faire 4
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour axel bonjour charles
je te remercie d'avoir accepté mon
invitation pour cet entretien à distance
fois n'est pas coutume toi tu tués du
côté de grenoble
si je ne m'abuse c'est bien ça eh bien
ça alors est ce que tu voudrais bien
c'est de te plaît te présenter pour les
spectateurs et nous dire pourquoi tu es
aujourd'hui oui alors donc moi je
m'appelle axel j'ai créé un site qui
s'appelle les sensibles c'est donc un
site au départ sur lequel je souhaitais
communiquer sur comme le nom l'indiqué
la sensibilité en particulier le
tempérament hypersensible donc en fait 7
cette idée m'est venue parce qu'on va
dire que j'ai rencontré certains
déboires du fait de son tempérament et
que j'ai compris un petit peu
tardivement
certaines de mes réactions et certaines
réactions de mon entourage à mon égard
et que j'ai connu et bien partager mon
expérience mes découvertes auprès
d'autres personnes qui peut-être
rencontré les mêmes difficultés que moi
alors on va on va avoir l'occasion un
peu d'approfondir ce sujet
l'hypersensibilité alors je précise
d'emblée le spectateur que tu as un site
internet
donc les 106 j'ai aussi une page
facebook une chaîne youtube
donc je paye tous les liens par une
petite chaîne youtube petite chaîne qui
démarre qui démarre quand j'ai mis tous
les liens sont en descriptions et je
précise également pour les personnes
je pense que sur un mur de l'entretien
les spectateurs auront l'occasion de
voir s'ils se sentent concernés par ce
sujet de l'hypersensibilité tu as
également créé une formation que je
propose sur mon site internet à
destination des personnes hypersensibles
1 face à une formation qui mélange
plusieurs supports des fiches des fiches
avec des textes dépendent à tchô de
l'audio un donc je mets je mets le lien
en descriptions pour les berceaux et
sachez que vous avez aussi accès à un
extrême de ces formations sur ma chaîne
comme ça vous pourrez vous faire une
idée et vous aurez cet entretien
également pour vous faire une idée
précise
est ce que tu pourrais nous expliquer en
quelques mots ce qu'on appelle
l'hypersensibilité alors une
hypersensibilité c'est un tempérament et
non pas une pathologie
donc ça il faut que ce soit très clair
d'entrée parce que sur internet sur de
nombreux sites
on entend enfin uni plutôt qu'une faut
guérir
l'hypersensibilité donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui m'énerve particulièrement
parce que parce que c'est un tempérament
de la même manière qu'on ne peut pas
changer à la couleur de ses yeux
comme je le dis souvent on ne peut pas
changer un tempérament hypersensible il
fait partie de nous on est né comme ça
et donc la meilleure chose que l'on a à
faire c'est de l'accepter de vivre avec
et de faire ce qu'il faut et
éventuellement pour faire sa croissance
personnelle pour se sentir bien avec ce
qu'on verra mans mais en tout cas c'est
pas quelque chose c'est pas un
tempérament qu'on doit qu'on doit cacher
qu'on doit rejeter c'est un tempérament
qui ne serait qu' on ressent des
émotions particulièrement forte ou que
ressentir en fait on ressent tous les
sens de manière particulièrement forte
donc ça plaît tant au niveau des
énergies
quand on va entrer dans une pièce on va
sentir les ambiances c'est évidemment
quand on rencontre une personne on va
tout de suite sentir donc l'âme état
d'esprit à l'aide
ça va être moi ce qui me touche
personnellement en tout cas c'est au
niveau du bruit une hypersensibilité aux
bruits donc je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont comme moi c'est à
dire quelle peine elles ont du mal avec
les environnements très bruyant
notamment d'entreprises les open space
et voilà c'est une grosse difficulté
donc l'hypersensibilité c'est ça c'est
ressentir de manière très forte
tout ce qui se passe dans son
environnement est en soi par tous ses
sens très bien
bon c'est très éclairant ça répond déjà
à des questions que j'avais prévu te
poser c'est vrai que le préfixe ils
perdent généralement un guide assure
développement donc quelque chose de
l'ordre de l'anomalie ce qui tendrait à
à nous faire croire que ce serait une
bateau logidoc tu dis bien ce n'est pas
une pathologie que c'est un tempérament
donc ça c'est intéressant et en plus le
mot sensibilité lui-même souvent en haut
on sait pas trop comment le définir la
sensibilité ce qui est intéressant dans
sa réponse et que tu ramènes le mot
sensibilité à son étymologie le les 100
ch
nos cinq sens et en fait c'est c'est sa
libération s'éviter savoir tous ses sens
s'ils ont une acuité développer hyper
développé ce serait ça l'idée ce serait
ça l'idée effectivement en fait c'est
donc ce lot selon elana onekey et une
psychologue américaine qui est celle qui
a le plus travaillé sur le sujet il y
aurait donc environ 20 personnes au
niveau de la peau d'un pour cent de
personnes pardon au niveau de la
population
alors je pense qu'elle accélère les
études donc aux états unis est temps
qu'il y en a 20 % de personnes qui
seraient doute être ce plan perramant là
avec une sensibilité accrue à leur
environnement et à leur perception à
leurs émotions
et à l'intérieur de ces 20% de personnes
il y aurait ce qu'on appelle les hauts
potentiels
les zèbres les surdoués voilà quelle que
soit la dénomination couple leurs
données qui eux-mêmes représenterait une
encore plus petite partie et donc tous
les toutes les personnes qui sont dites
à haut potentiel serait hyper sensible
mais tous les hyper sensibles ne sont
pas au potentiel est là qu il faut bien
faire la distinction
du coup j'ai un petit peu perdues de
chine ce qui est aussi une
caractéristique des tempéraments
hypersensible c'est qu'on parle un petit
peu dans tous les sens producteurs sont
à feuilles la de loi qui devrait me
chômé pour y aller progressivement pas
aller trop vite même si d'avoir pété
sont ils surviennent
est-ce que sk ta connaissance monde est
d'accord avec cette définition
d'hypersensibilité sk une définition qui
fasse consensus
une définition entre guillemets
scientifique de l'hypersensibilité ou
what a connaissance alors à ma
connaissance malheureusement il ya assez
peu de personnes qui en fait des
recherches scientifiques sur le sujet
donc outre les dan haren la psychologue
américaine que je viens de citer
il y a quelqu'un en france un
psychologue qui a sermonné qui est
également auteur qui est saverio
tomasella qu'il a écrit plusieurs livres
sur le sujet
les tweets ou ces personnes-là
s'accordent sur une même définition de
fer sensibilité mais c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours trouvé qu'il n'y avait pas
assez d'études sur le sujet du coup ça
ça ça nous laisse assez perplexe
enfin moi quand j'ai fait des recherches
j'étais assez étonné de trouver
finalement aussi peu de documentation
sur le sujet en dehors de ces deux
personnes qui sont les plus connus il ya
ces petits antifi cas malheureusement
qui sont penchés sur la question
à l'origine en fait il se trouve que une
bonne partie la majorité des personnes
hypersensibles ou également de
tempérament introverti et donc elle a
narbonne a appuyé ses recherches sur le
psychiatre carl jung qui lui a beaucoup
parlé à des tempéraments introverti mais
voilà le tempérament introverti c'est je
crois
soixante dix où 80% des personnes
hypersensibles mais il ya aussi des
personnes qui sont hyper sensible et
extravertie donc en dehors de ces
personnes là que j'ai cités et la navale
saverio tomasella et donc monsieur young
voilà qui ce monde il ya à ma
connaissance est assez peu de recherche
d'étudiants alors ça fait intéressant
donc je j'ai envie de demander à nos
spectateurs de mettre dans les
commentaires les sources éventuellement
d'études qui aurait pu être être mené
sur sur cette question de
l'hypersensibilité comme ça ça permet
aussi ça permet aussi de partager les
informations pour ceux que ça intéresse
pour ne pas tomber aussi dans dans le
jugement un peu à l'emporte-pièce parce
que des fois qu'on pro quand on entend
des personnes parler d'hypersensibilité
on a un peu l'impression que c'est un
mot qui permet un mot un peu fourre tout
qui permet aussi de mettre des choses
très différentes de dents au point que
l'on sait plus vraiment ce que ça veut
dire quoi tu proposes tu aimes une
définition assez précises qui ouvre
d'ailleurs sur beaucoup de questions et
ça va être un peu l'objet de notre
entretien
donc voilà un appel aux spectateurs
partagent et c'est là tout le monde
puisse en profiter
ça me permet de rebondir sur notre
question que je vous ai exposé qui est
est ce que être hyper sensible est ce
que c'est un handicap
évidemment ces questions un peu mais il
est un peu provocante mais je t'entends
des parler du fait que les personnes
hypersensibles été capable de ressentir
les ambiances d énergie particulière
j'ai envie de dire ça c'est plutôt bien
ça ressemble à un pouvoir
est ce que c'est un handicap est ce que
c'est un atout parce que c'est les deux
voilà ce que les soeurs alors moi
aujourd'hui je suis persuadé que c'est
une force
évidemment en pha sinon je n'aurais pas
construit un site internet et beaucoup
travailler pour faire un podcast des
articles et et essayer de faire passer
mon message qui est que la sensibilité
doit être plus valorisées en société et
qu'elle est essentielle dans notre monde
donc voilà pour moi clairement c'est une
force
mais pour beaucoup de personnes
hypersensibles c'est au départ un vécu
comme un handicap parce que bas parce
que tout simplement comme toutes les
minorités puisque les personnes
hypersensibles sont une minorité ou la
population générale
on se sent très différents et on se sent
très incompris notamment quand on ne
connaît pas encore notre tempérament
quand on n'a pas encore appris quand on
n'a pas fait ça avec sa connaissance de
soi quand on n'a pas appris à connaître
ses limites ses besoins
donc au départ ça peut être vécu comme
un handicap parce que ressentir des
émotions très fortes en permanence ça
prend beaucoup d'énergie et donc on a un
niveau d'énergie en général qui est
limité et donc il faut bien se connaître
pour savoir comment gérer notre énergie
suivant après chaque personne est
différente les personnes hypersensibles
n'échappe pas à la règle là on trace des
grandes généralités il ya des ya des
caractéristiques communes qui reviennent
mais après chaque personne évidemment va
vivre cela différemment et chaque
personne va avoir ses caractéristiques à
elle
mais voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya vraiment
le développement personnel est la
connaissance de soi et est très
importante pour une personne de
tempérament hyper sensible parce qu'au
début elle se sent vraiment à comprise
elle ne comprend pas ces réactions
émotionnelles
elle ne comprend pas non plus les
réactions des autres à son égard donc
c'est un petit peu perturbant et il ya
d'autres caractéristiques de
personnalités notamment souvent une
anxiété qu'il faut que c'est un
tempérament qui parfois est un petit peu
difficile à vivre au départ voilà quand
on connaît pas bien tu disais que les
personnes hypersensibles étaient en
minorité
est ce que ça signifie que la majorité
s'inscrit dans un autre dans un autre
schéma de fonctionnement pour être plus
précis souvent on a tendance à opposer
la sensibilité et la raison est ce que
tu dirais du coup que nous sommes dans
le rationnel il perd rationnelle mais
met donc la sensibilité à l'écart bien
est ce que c'est pour d'autres raisons
que les personnes hypersensibles alors
déjà de mon point de vue on peut la type
r sensible et utiliser sa raison c'est
pas du tout incompatible
donc c'est pas c'est pas ce niveau là
que je vous mettrais une différenciation
mais simplement c'est davantage au
niveau culturel
on vit donc les hyper sensible a encore
une fois ça se joue vraiment au niveau
d'hypersensibilité ça joue vraiment au
niveau émotionnel et ses émotions ou
peut les accueillir ou que les apaiser
c'est quelque chose qui s'apprend
les émotions comme je le dis souvent
c'est un c'est un message c'est le gps
de notre vie donc elles sont là pour
nous aider à prendre des décisions
également quand on les comprend et quand
on les écoute
du coup pour moi les émotions c'est pas
du tout incompatible avec le fait de
prendre des décisions de raisonner né
dans notre culture on a tendance à
négliger
[Musique]
quelque peu l'intelligence émotionnelle
et à se focaliser sur l'intelligence
cognitive sûr en fait sur certains
aspects de l'intelligence
alors on sait aujourd'hui que
l'intelligence est multiple
l'intelligence et s'est jamais selon moi
qu'une capacité d'adaptation à son
environnement et cette capacité
d'adaptation
elle peut se faire également grâce aux
émotions pour lui selon moi c'est pas
s'est pas imposé après c'est une
question un petit peu piagge aussi dans
le sens où je ne voudrais pas qu'on
laisse dire que comme je l'entends
parfois comme je le lis parfois sur
certains types de sites que les hyper
sensible sous une sorte de caste à part
deux personnes merveilleuses
bienveillante qui n'ont aucun défaut et
fin tu vois il ya des sites comme ça qui
font des articles qui brossent les
personnes hypersensibles dans le sens du
poil
parce que est passé du pit à cliquer un
tout simplement faim voilà c'est c'est
des articles destinés à être clic et
partager un maximum pour va pouvoir
gagner de la de pouvoir faire sa
monétisation publicitaire tout
simplement
c'est un système de monétisation comme
un autre et du coup on lit parfois des
choses ou kid à se penser que les hyper
sensible se sentent voilà des personnes
au dessus au dessus de la moyenne parce
qu'elles ont cette sensibilité très
développé et c'est alors la sensibilité
pour moi c'est une qualité très
clairement mais je suis vraiment contre
voilà ce point de vue là qui veut dire
que on est au dessus des autres
non pas du tout
des personnes comme les autres avec nos
défauts nos qualités notre tempérament
spécifiques
tout le monde a de la sensibilité en
soit je pense l'être humain l'être
humain est sensible
après c'est simplement que le contexte
social le contexte culturel le contexte
familial enfin l'environnement encore
une fois fait qu'on va développer ou pas
cette sensibilité les circonstances de
la vie peuvent faire que on étouffe
cette sensibilité déjà parce qu'elle est
mal acceptée par la société
un homme ne pleure pas par exemple c'est
bien connu
un homme n'a pas le droit de pleurer
voilà donc derrière tout ça il ya
beaucoup comme comme très souvent il ya
beaucoup deux croyances limitantes petit
oiseau qui nous sont inculquées par
notre culture notre environnement mais
mon message c'est vraiment de dire que
les personnes hypersensibles sont pas au
dessus des autres
et d'ailleurs moi toutes les personnes
hypersensibles que j'ai pu rencontrer ce
sont en général des personnes qui ont un
certain déficit d steam de soi qui se
sont pas au dessus des autres bien au
contraire qui souffrent bien souvent du
syndrome de l'imposteur qui sont des
personnes bienveillantes mais qui se
laisse bouffer parfois par les autres
qui sont des personnes qui peuvent se
faire manipuler ce ne sont pas pour
autant des personnes faibles c'est pas
non plus je veux pas qu'on interprète
mes propos dans ce sens là mais en tout
cas ce sont vraiment des personnes
bienveillantes et quand elles n'ont pas
appris à connaître leur tempérament il à
connaître leurs limites
ça peut voilà ça peut ça peut amener ce
genre de désagrément dans les relations
sociales
on en reparlera peut-être on peut même
commencer parce que tu vas parler de
syndrome oui alors le syndrome de
l'imposteur c'est de fait de penser
qu'on n'est pas à sa place
alors souvent ça se joue au niveau
professionnel et ça n'a rien à voir avec
le nombre de diplômes qu'on a pu
décrocher
l'expérience que l'on peut n'avoir il ya
des personnes qui ont des bacs plus
simple des bac + 8 qui sont érudite qui
sont intelligentes et qui ont le
syndrome de l'imposteur
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
n'a rien à voir avec son niveau de
culture générale
son niveau de voilà deux d'intelligence
d'éducation ça n'a rien à voir avec
aucun de ces critères on peut en
souffrir
on peut on peut se dire typiquement
sabbath des phrases du genre oh là là
mais ils vont s'apercevoir qu'en fait je
suis nul voilà où par exemple quelqu'un
qui va se voir confier une mission en
entreprise et qui désirent ouhlala je ne
me sens pas du tout à la hauteur là
alors que cette personne à la tout à
fait des coupes de tence donc moi je
rencontre des personnes qui souffrent de
ça en accompagnement des personnes très
éduquée très cultivé voilà je travaille
notamment avec des enseignantes et est
souvent voilà c'est un déficit destine
de soi en fait le syndrome de
l'imposteur alors le mot syndrome
pourrait laisser penser encore une fois
une maladie pour s'est juste fait un
impair psychologique on va dire tout
simplement un déficit de style de soi
qui laisse penser que l'homme n'est pas
sa place dans certaines circonstances de
la vie professionnelle ou de la vie
privée alors qu'en fait si on regarde
objectivement les choses c'est pas le
cas
ben je sais pas si j'ai été très clair
si tu veux mais je compte rester c'était
très clair là encore ça pose beaucoup de
questions je pense que le spectateur qui
nous regardent pensa
tout de suite ça fait penser à des
situations où wade des cas où
effectivement on peut se retrouver dans
cette situation là jeune rom de
l'imposteur c'est ce serait un sentiment
d'illégitimité permanente qui serait due
comme tu dis à un manque d'estimé de soi
parce que après tout pourquoi partir du
principe que l'autre est d'ailleurs que
moi pourquoi partir du principe que je
ne suis pas capable 2
c'est vrai que ça soulève énormément de
questions alors aux côtés de continuer
pour voir si ça s'éclaircit pour rentrer
un peu dans le concret comment sait-on
qu'on est hypersensible
il ya des choses qui permettent des
marqueurs qui permettent vraiment de
d'identifier universel alors de ma
propre expérience et des lectures que
j'ai pu faire
il ya des grands traits de personnalité
que l'on retrouve en comminges et toutes
les personnes au tempérament
hypersensible sabbath souvent une haute
exigence vis-à-vis de soi-même
donc dans le travail par exemple une
haute exigence de qualité culinaire très
souvent au perfectionnisme puisque pour
moi il ya toujours un revers de la
médaille tout les toutous les tout ce
qu'on considère comme des défauts soit
en fait le revers d'une qualité et il
suffit simplement de trouver le juste
équilibre pour en faire une force
donc cette haute exigence pour moi de
qualité c'est une force
quand ça vire au perfectionnisme ça ça
devient un des shows qu'il faut chercher
un rééquilibre donc ça c'est vraiment
voilà l'exigence qui peuvent ils au
perfectionnisme c'est vraiment un des
grands traits ensuite ça va souvent une
grande anxiété qui peut être généralisé
et qui peut qui peut être aussi souvent
dans le domaine social c'est-à-dire une
anxiété une part des autres une anxiété
sous le regard
des eaux d'une part du jugement des
autres c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
moi même souffert de ça d'une grande
anxiété sociale et ma formation de
sérénité en société elle est axée en
grande partie sur sur cette
problématique là donc voilà
perfectionnisme et anxiété la
sensibilité fait que on peut être doué
d'une grande empathie
c'est à dire une capacité à se mettre à
la place des autres et apprendre ce que
la personne ressent donc cette empathie
elle est évidemment très intéressante
pour tous les métiers de
l'accompagnement et elle a également son
revers de la médaille c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on est trop dans la sympathie la
compassion et non plus l'empathie on
peut se faire bouffer par les émotions
des autres c'est à dire absorbé par
exemple l'énergie négative d'une
personne qui n'est pas bien dans sa peau
et se sentira donc absorber cette cette
énergie négative se sentir à son tour a
mal mais voilà donc l'empathie donc à
chaque fois je suis mme intéressant de
citer la qualité et le défaut quand
cette qualité n'est pas équilibré
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres comme ben
rentrait alors on peut avoir d'autres
une hypersensibilité au bruit une
hypersensibilité aux lumières très forte
on a souvent un amour
moi c'est ce que j'appelle mon sens de
l'esthétique c'est à dire qu'on aime ce
qui est beau ce qui est harmonieux wyss
le ski choix de notre sens de
l'esthétique peu qu'on aime voilà être
dans un bel environnement
que les choses soient agréables à
regarder voilà ça ça me fait penser donc
le sens de l'esthétique qu'on a
généralement un besoin profond de se
ressourcer dans la nature la nature
c'est très important parce que ça nous
reconnecte comment dire à skis l'homme
au départ à à ce qu'on a tous au fond
nous donc ça nous aide à nous à nous
recentrer à à nous remettre en place a
retrouvé en fait notre place dans le
monde
la nature c'est extrêmement important
pour les personnes hypersensibles pour
se ressourcer
parce que ça apporte beaucoup
d'apaisement de calme ça aide à ça aide
à stabiliser les émotions on a souvent
besoin aussi de de calme et donc de se
ressourcer également dans la solitude en
particulier pour les personnes qui sont
introvertis donc ce qui est quand même
la majorité des personnes au tempérament
hypersensible ça c'est un besoin très
profond c'est à dire que une personne
hypersensible et introverti qui va
travailler par exemple dans un open
space
selon moi fatalement un jour ou l'autre
elle va être malade on peut pas c'est
trop c'est c'est ça dépasse nos limites
ça n'est pas ce qu'on est capable
d'accepter le bruit permanent après tout
dépend des open space
il y en a peut-être qui sont très calmes
et et dans lesquels se passe très bien
mais en tout cas on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas vivre confortablement longtemps
dans un endroit extrêmement bruyant avec
beaucoup de monde et beaucoup
d'agitation autour de soi il a vraiment
besoin de deux plages de solitude ou de
calme pour se ressourcer se recharger en
énergie en fait puisque la différence
entre les personnes extraverties des
personnes introverties c'est la
personnes extraverties a besoin
énormément du contact des autres
en général la personne str averti ne
supporte pas la solitude recharge ses
batteries au contact des autres îles
introverti bas c'est tout le contraire
c'est quelqu'un qui va qui va avoir
besoin pour harkis qui peut être avec un
certain nombre de personnes allaient
dans des soirées etc
un spectacle est possible mais au bout
d'un moment il va avoir besoin de
rentrer chez lui au calme et voilà et ce
succès tranquillement nous avons droit
tranquille donc là c'est vraiment les
principaux traits de caractère que je
retrouve chez personne que j'ai pu
rencontrer donc le l'exigence qui vire
au perfectionnisme l'anxiété la
bienveillance et l'empathie et je sais
plus le dernier que j'ai hésité
voilà c'est la solitude
voilà le cas recensés dans la nature et
la nature oui c'est vrai l'introverti
l'extraverti bon ça a l'air d'être des
opposés mais si on écoutait tout cas si
on a une lecture un peu non linéaire des
choses c'est pas d opposer finalement
l'introverti extravertie pour ma part je
ça m'arrive de rencontrer des personnes
extraverties en apparence c'est à dire
qu'ils ont l'air de contact facile avec
les gens qui vont facilement parler à
des inconnus
mais on peut sentir dès fois on peut
sentir une forme de l'exagération de jeu
presque comme si ce caractère extraverti
cacher quelque chose
c'est alors je veux pas tomber dans les
clichés peut-être que tu te croirais
certains clichés mais c'est vrai que
souvent on dit que les personnes qui
adorent faire de l'humour tout temps
sont des personnes qui sont pas
forcément heureuse à l'intérieur et de
façon les personnes qui ont l'air très
extraverti sont des personnes qui
parfois se sentent un petit peu seul et
incomprise y est ce que ça c'est en lien
avec l'hyper sensibilité le caractère
extraverti bas selon quoi et est ce que
le s que l'introverti et l'extraverti ne
sont pas les deux faces de la même pièce
alors je pense qu'il faut encore une
fois resituer dans le contexte culturel
on est clairement dans une culture qui
favorise l'extraversion ce qui fait que
certaines personnes pour s'intégrer au
sein d'un groupe où pour se sentir plus
en phase avec les autres peuvent jouer à
être extraverti
même si ce n'est pas leur nature
profonde selon moi on peut pas être
extraverti et introverti à la fois on
est soit l'un soit l'autre donc pour ça
il faut aller lire les études de
monsieur young justement qui a travaillé
son tempérament introverti par contre
effectivement on peut porter un masque
parce que en société parce que ça va
nous arranger à un moment donné on sait
aussi qu'il ya parfois des personnes qui
sont de grands timides qui nie et qui
choisit de mettre le masque du clown
parce que bas parce que ça les aide
c'est leur façon à elle de s'intégrer
dans la société dans un groupe
alors pourquoi pas il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas de jugement à porter sur ce type
d'attitude
mais selon moi on ne peut pas être les
deux tempéraments à la fois que
simplement avoir une attitude qui laisse
penser que et mais au fond de soi voilà
on est soit introverti soit extraverti
et je pense que c'est vraiment important
de respecter ce tempérament là il n'y a
pas de août à voir l'un n'est pas mieux
que l'autre
il est comme ça c'est également un
tempérament tout comme une
hypersensibilité est également il ya de
gros amalgames qui sont faits entre le
tchad est introverti et la sociabilité
une personne introvertie peut être tout
à fait une personne sociable n'a rien à
voir moi personnellement j'adore
rencontrer des gens je suis absolument
pas timide je suis tout à fait à l'aise
quand je rencontre des personnes la
première fois en tête la teinte chez
extrêmement à l'aise
par contre en groupe ça va me poser plus
de difficultés je vais plus en retrait
parce que en groupe
il va y avoir du bruit il va y avoir
beaucoup d'agitation autour de moi donc
là mon tempérament hypersensible et
introverti vet - moins à l'aise avec ce
contexte là et dont je vais me tenir
plus en retrait et au bout d'un moment
si je suis dans une soirée je vais être
fatigué et je vais avoir besoin au bout
de quelques heures voilà de de me
ressourcer dans le calme mais ça
n'empêche pas que je suis sociable et je
parle de moi mais voilà c'est pour tout
le monde pareil donc les introvertis ne
sont pas des gros asociaux enfermés dans
leur grotte un voile à fait vrai que
souvent c'est un peu l'image concentre
effectivement c'est pas c'est pas
valoriser la personne introvertie est
une personne qui qui en général ne parle
pas pour ne rien dire qui n'équivalent
plus à l'aise à l'écrit qu'à l'oral qui
va avoir besoin de réfléchir avant de
donner son point de vue mais c'est pas
une personne qui a une chaise en société
pas du tout après elle peut l'être en
plus mais ça fait pas partie du
tempérament introverti que d'être mal à
l'aise en société c'est simplement à une
histoire de niveau d'énergie
encore une fois on n'a pas la même
énergie pour tous
les personnes hypersensibles vont mettre
leur énergie dans la créativité par
exemple voilà elle vous - la mettre à
faire la fête dans sein d'une grande
voie là d'un grand groupe de personnel
vont préférer les relations intimiste et
peut-être parce qu'elles préfèrent des
relations profondes justement alors
qu'une personne extractives je dis pas
qu'une personne est averti n'aime pas
les relations joue également
mais une personnes extraverties ce
qu'elle aime surtout c'est le contact le
contact humain
une personne introvertie préfère
peut-être la qualité à la quantité si je
puis dire je vais me faire j'ai fait
rage en disant ça mais s'en tire
exactement
on comprend l'idée en plus de ça ce que
tu dis
quand on regarde vraiment les choses en
face c'est très clair ce que tu dis ça
ça résonne ça fait tu veux ça on a tout
de suite les images on voit très bien
les personnes extrêmement très
extraverti très à l'aise ça se voit dans
l'eure dans leurs mouvements dans leur
gestuelle
voilà maintenant leurs intonations des
personnes qui sont capables de mettre en
contact d'être en contact avec les
autres mais par définition si on est en
contact avec mon nom peut pas être dans
une relation de profondeur ou
d'exclusivité avec chacune de ces
personnes là qu'ils excellent quand on
passe 3h 4h 5h a parlé avec personne en
tête on développe une relation
on ne peut pas avoir simplement avec par
échange de quelques mots et si on devait
multiplier cette relation des changes
par le nombre de personne ne comprenait
que ça très compliqué donc oui tu as
raison d'une certaine manière tout court
du signal et que un moment donné on ne
peut pas avoir et la qualité et la
quantité la personnes extraverties c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque où dans la cantine et
c'est par un jugement moral à les
critiques c'est un simple constat de
fonctionnement
est ce que parce que je veux pas oublier
ma question faire parler de la
créativité est ce qu'il y aurait une
prédisposition des personnes
hypersensibles aux revenir vraiment au
coeur des sujets prédisposition à l'art
ou à la création
j'ai pas de jets pas de réponse à ta
portée sur la question parce que ça
serait juste ma propre expérience des
personnes que j'ai rencontrées qui
toutes sont relativement créative mais
j'avoue que j'ai pas d'études j'ai pas
lu d'études sur cette question précise
pour que malheureusement je ne pourrai
pas t'en dire plus sur ce point là mais
il me semble que les plus grands
artistes étaient tous étaient ou sont
tous des personnes qui sont quelque part
alors je vais employer un mot qui a une
connotation un peu négative mais des
personnes qui sont un peu torturé dans
le sens où quelqu'un qui est
complètement en paix avec ses émotions
qui a trouvé un équilibre qui est dans
la sérénité
cette personne là elle peut pas vraiment
créé à ce qu'elle n'a pas de matériaux
sur lequel s'appuyer donc dans ce sens
les personnes qui sont un peu torturé
par les émotions comme peuvent l'être
les personnes hypersensibles sont des
personnes par essence créative parce qu
elles utilisent leurs émotions et elle
et elle les extériorise de cette façon
là ça les aide à se propre l'un des
motions qui bouillonne en n va
s'exprimer par la créativité qui peut
être décrit turquie plaide le dessin la
peinture la chanson la danse et peu
importe ça va ou les activités manuelles
donc ça va s'exprimer ainsi donc mais ça
voilà c'est un point de vue tout à fait
personnelle qui est pas étayé par des
études on préfère le préciser je ne suis
pas penché sur cette question là mais là
aussi j'habite les les spectateurs
actuellement à partager leurs leurs
recherches
sauf les informations sur cette question
du lien entre hypersensibilité ehs vous
pour concerne l'art la création je te
rejoins d'un point de vue plus
philosophique on dire que l'artiste
l'archétype je parle de l'arctique
chaque personne individuellement mais
l'artiste souvent à quelque chose à
extérioriser a exprimé un des deux mots
d'ailleurs ont la même racine et pour
exprimer quelque chose il faut avoir
quelque chose à exprimer
j'ai envie de dire que l'artiste s'il
n'avait rien à exprimer ne s'était pas
artiste et que ce côté torturé
cette forme de souffrance employés
internes
le général c'est c'est le matériau de
l'artiste sinon il n'aurait pas besoin
de faire de l'art ils éprouveraient pas
cette espèce de le besoin impérieux
d'exprimer quelque chose si tout allait
bien
son parler s'il n'y avait rien n'y avait
pas de relief à l'intérieur de lui qui
fait qu'il a besoin d'exprimer quelques
semences en tout cas voilà que je reste
prudente mans dans ce lien donc chacun 3
à les approfondir la question
alors je continue j'enchaîne un petit
peu parce que le le temps passer on
aurait envie de vraiment de rester
pendant des heures à parler de ce sujet
parce qu'il ya énormément de c'est à
dire qu'elles sont selon toi d'après ton
expérience entraîné les conséquences de
l'hypersensibilité au niveau social au
niveau sentimental éventuellement niveau
scolaire aussi parce que malgré sa
chaîne ma chaîne pardon s'adresse aux
parents d'élèves pour tout ce qui est
autour de l'apprentissage et il ya
beaucoup d'élèves et d'enfants qui sont
également concernés par une hyper
sensibilité
au niveau des conséquences plutôt
négative le libé ressenti dès qu'est ce
que tu pourrais lui dire
alors j'ai déjà un petit peu abordé ce
point c'est cette tendance à l'anxiété
qui peut se retrouver dans deux dans le
milieu social donc que voilà on peut
souffrir beaucoup
donc en fait selon ma propre théorie
l'anxiété sociale en crète au niveau du
dsm qui est la bible des psychiatres
américains est considérée comme une
pathologie d'anxiété sociale la phobie
sociale voilà suivant le degré de
souffrance que la personne vit alors moi
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça
voilà très clairement j'ai d'ailleurs
écrit deux articles sur le sujet selon
moi l'anxiété sociale c'est simplement
un déficit d estime de soi parce que la
personne qui est anxieuse dans société
sbo tel souffle c'est du regard des
autres
donc ça paraît tout à fait logique de se
dire que si on se préoccupe du regard
des autres
c'est qu'on se sent pas tout à fait bien
dans ses baskets
ça me paraît une réduction voilà puisque
plus que logique
donc ça c'est une des tendances qu'une
personne très sensible peut avoir
tendance à souffrir de la peur du
jugement des autres et plus généralement
de la peur d'avoir peur c'est à dire que
ça va très loin
on peut avoir fait des crises d'angoissé
à un moment dans sa vie même une crise
d'angoissé dans sa vie et gardez
toujours en soit cette peur que cela
recommence
même si ça n'est pas même si ça ne s'est
pas produit a depuis plusieurs années la
crise d'angoissé quelque chose de très
très très fort enfin on a l'impression
qu'on est tous
on va mourir voilà il ya des personnes
qui nous qui ont appelé les pompiers
parce qu'elle pour ça qu'elle faisait un
malaise cardiaque à ox ac c'est pas du
tout quelque chose d'anodin pour les
angoisses avant quelque chose de très de
très handicapant et qui génère beaucoup
de souffrance et donc on a le fait
d'avoir à un moment de sa vie souffert
de ça serait que l'on va continuer à
traîner avec soin cette peur comme un
boulet tout au long de sa vie y est et à
être dans la tente quelque part dans
l'attenté anxieuse que cela recommence
dans la peur perpétuelle que cela
recommence donc ça se voit la scène
quatre caractéristiques que je retrouve
très souvent chez les personnes de mon
père à mon père sensible donc ta
question c'était en société un lait les
conséquences voilà les cancers dans
certains domaines social scolaire des
jeunes d'entraînement professionnel
sentimentale aussi sa patte intéressant
je me posais la question quand tu
parlais tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que ça fait tomber deux
hypersensibles ensemble est-ce que ça
peut ça donne lieu à des situations un
peu un peu bizarre alors que sa dépense
qui s'ils sont équilibrés avec leur
hypersensibilité ou non en fait ça
dépend de leur niveau de connaissance de
soi je dirai pas ce qu'on plus on peut
tout à fait être hyper sensible et puis
et puis au clair avec son tempérament et
bien dans sa vie et ses relations
donc voilà ça dépend vraiment de est ce
qu'on a fait ce travail sur soi ou pas
après la caractéristique des personnes
hypersensibles keys qui souffre d'un
déficit de steam de soi c'est qu'elles
ont tendance à à souffrir de dépendance
affective donc à s'accrocher dans la
mesure où elles ressentent l'amitié
comme l'amour comme tous les sentiments
de manière très forte a beau s'accrocher
très fort aux personnes qu'elles vont
rencontrer très fort mais très vite et
si la personne de l'autre côté n'est pas
dans le même ressenti ou si la personne
de l'autre côté n'a pas le même niveau
de sensibilité
ça va être compliqué parce que ça a
senti un petit peu étouffée du coup ça
peut gêner des relations ça peut générer
des relations amoureuses
parce que générer de la souffrance dans
les relations amoureuses pour la
personne hypersensible qui n'est pas
encore tout à fait qu'ils voudraient
qu'il a pas encore réussi à stabiliser
son estime de soi donc voilà les
relations amoureuses et en fait de
manière générale cette dépendance
affective elle peut se retrouver partout
même au niveau professionnel c'est à
dire qu'on peut être amené à s'attacher
à à quelqu'un dans son travail et et ça
peut donc ça peut générer forcément des
problèmes au niveau relationnel puisque
voilà toujours à cause des émotions
lorsqu'elles ne sont pas lorsqu'elles ne
sont pas apaisées lorsqu'elles ne sont
pas accueillis et compris au niveau
alors au niveau scolaire j'ai pas
vraiment d'expérience moi je travaille
essentiellement avec des adultes pas
avec des enfants donc je m'aime
malheureusement je vais pas voir c'est
dommage c'est grâce à ce type de
personnel et ouais c'est ça sera un
sujet que je traiterai par la suite
libérés dans le cadre scolaire parce que
par rapport à tout ce qui est justement
phobie scolaire ou à tout ce qui peut
être difficultés d'adaptation au cadre
scolaire
je pense que la question du père
sensibilité de choses importantes
maintenant voilà ça ça permettra d'abord
froid n'a pas de d'expérience dans ce
domaine en particulier
non je peux avancer parce que je veux
pas dire des bêtises des choses que jean
n'a pas été une valeur par des arguments
par des recherches personnelles et puis
je pense que là aussi il ya beaucoup d'
amalgame dont il faut se méfier entre
l'hyper sensibilité les hauts potentiels
l'hyperréactivité certains enfants non
je m'avancerai pas sur la question parce
que je pense que j'ai pas fait de
recherches sur le sujet mais c'est
vraiment intéressant à creuser et cemac
si tu as l'occasion toi même de causer
ce sujet là je regarderai avec les états
vidéo je t'enverrai le lien
on va on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien même question que je me pose
un petit peu bête et naïve
est-ce qu'on peut être hyper sensible
sans le savoir
et dans ce cas là qu'est ce qui se passe
comment comment on fait est ce que toi
par exemple tu connais des astuces ou
des des choses à mettre en place pour
savoir si on est hyper sensible ou bien
est ce que c est ce qu on peut être
hyper sensible mais on va avoir une
conscience
ouais alors moi je l' ai découvert vers
mes 40 ans c'est vraiment relativement
récent parce que je suis dans ma
quarante septième année
donc oui on peut tout à fait apte
hypersensible sans le savoir et
justement se pose beaucoup de questions
ces essais à force de se poser des
questions je pensais à force de ne pas
se comprendre soi et de ne pas
comprendre le monde dans lequel on vit
aussi les réactions des autres pour
faire ses propres recherches et qu'on en
arrive à découvrir qu'on est con est
doté de ce tempérament là moi je me suis
posé des questions parce que j'ai fait
un burn-out
dans ma dernière entreprise puisque j'ai
été salarié de ma vie voilà jusqu'en
2016 et et j'y serai notamment un
burn-out à cause du bruit alors y avait
plusieurs
il y avait plusieurs raisons c'est est
multifactoriel mais le point de départ
ça y est ça je travaille avec des
personnes très brillante et je ne
supportais pas et est du coup je me suis
beaucoup interrogée parce que évidemment
je suis allé par la médecine du travail
je suis responsable j'ai de résoudre la
problématique en interne et et j'avais
l'impression d'être lâcheuse de service
1 pour être un peu mal colis des zones
et charles mais de 2,2 pas trouvé d'écho
de battre prise au sérieux en fait dans
ma problématique pour moi c'était une
grosse brosse ou en ce que je vivais et
je réalisais qu'on fasse je n'ai pas
prise au sérieux je ne sais pas comment
dire les choses autrement
les gens ne réalisent pas à quel point
j'étais en souffrance à cause de ce
problème de bruit et du coup je me suis
posé beaucoup de questions et c'est
comme ça que j'ai découvert mon
hypersensibilité et là il ya plein de
choses qui sont éclairés
parce que petit à petit en creusant des
lectures j'ai compris plein de choses
qui n'est arrivé dans ma vie plein de
réactions que jamais eu pour après moi
j'ai un
j'ai eu une enfance blessée donc je suis
déjà à la base j'ai une faille beaucoup
de personnes ou leurs feuilles et mais
je les déductions que j'avais capture
mois à l'origine était fausse et elles
se font expliquer en grande partie par
mon tempérament hypersensible donc en
fait quand on découvre st on a à la fois
un grand soulagement de se dire ah ok
c'est pour ça que je réagis comme ça et
on est soulagé de savoir qu'on n'est pas
seul à être comme ça aussi ça c'est très
aidant de rencontrer d'autres personnes
de lire des témoignages de de voir qu'on
n'est pas seuls au monde avec son
tempérament et donc je dirais que la clé
quand on sent qu'on a des problématiques
relationnel parce qu'à mon avis ça se
joue essentiellement là l'être humain
est un animal sociable donc les
problématiques assauts souvent
relationnel
ça va être dans le travail s'arrête dans
la vie amicale amoureuse les loisirs
il faut il faut faire des recherches il
faut il faut aller voir un psychologue
il faut lire des livres à essayer de
comprendre de chercher sur internet
pas moi c'est ce que j'ai fait je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a enfin un savoir
immense à notre portée avec internet et
je veux vraiment pas s'en priver
j'ai pas d'autres clés a donné que
celle-ci on se rend compte qu'on est
hypersensible quand on est en souffrance
de ces relations
c'est vraiment ça avec avec dévoila d
émotion débordante avec
le l'impression de ne pas être compris à
comprise par les autres de nous dit mais
tu es trop sensible mes études mais
c'est pas grave mais tu prends toujours
trop à coeur
voilà puis ce grand cette grande
exigence qui vire au perfectionnisme
aussi et puis cette impression d'être en
décalage avec le monde de ne pas
comprendre un côté un peu naïve chance
est bienveillant mais un peu naïve de se
dire les commet
comment c'est possible qu'on puisse
infliger autant de souffrances dans le
monde
ça c'est incompréhensible pour les
personnes hypersensibles
c'est et moi je déraille un peu du sujet
à l'avenir
pardon je fais une diète médiatique
depuis quelques années et c'est vraiment
ce que je conseille à toutes les
personnes qui l'ont tempérament très
sensible parce que nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de porter sur les épaules toute
la souffrance du monde
ça nous touche un point qui peut nous
empêcher de vivre sereinement de vivre
heureusement et donc malheureusement il
faut ce que je dis souvent c'est que il
faut penser à soi avant tout pour rendre
le monde meilleur
parce que quand on soit on est plus
équilibrée où peut on est plus à même
d'être bienveillant avec les autres et
de diffuser de bonheur autour de soi et
donc nécessairement on doit avoir cet
égoïsme que que je considère être de la
générosité envers soi même
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus l'égoïsme
c'est pas quelque chose de mal c'est de
la générosité envers soi même parce que
si on n'est pas capable de vivre
correctement avec son tempérament ça va
forcément se ressentir sur notre
entourage sur nos relations et à partir
du moment où on se connaît on accepte ce
pont perramant qu'on fait sa croissance
personnelle
on va être capable d'être plus serein là
donc d'apporter
si pluie de bonheur aux autres donc là
j'ai largement axé mes larmes
digressions ça fait partie de partie des
choses qui arrivent mais un bonus parce
que tu vivre ce que je valais ce que je
voulais dire c'est que il faut pas se
sentir coupable de scoops et parfois des
actualités télévisées
parce que les médias sont que c'est de
telle sorte qu'ils sont là avant tout
pour vous occuper l'esprit nous empêcher
de nous révolter et quelque part enfin
moi je vois les choses un petit peu
comme ça quand on est préoccupé par
toutes les souffrances qu'il ya dans le
monde que notre esprit omnibulé par ça
or on peut pas on peut pas s'occuper de
faire la révolution en quelque sorte et
ça c'est ça nous donne une vision très
anxiogène du monde qui ne nous pousse
pas à être dans la bienveillance et dans
l'harmonie
alors je dis pas qu'on le doit être plié
ne pas se tenir au courant etc
mais je dis qu'un qu'il faut trier ses
sources d'information il faut essayer de
faire la part des choses entre les
actualités télévisées anxiogène qui ne
nous montre que la face obscure du monde
et peut-être des actualités qui vont
nous montrer des choses toutes les
choses bien qui se passe aussi dans le
monde parce qu'il y en a tous les jours
et donc faut vraiment apprendre à se
concentrer sur le positif sur les belles
choses qui se passe autour de nous et à
se préserver de ce qui est mauvais de ce
qui nous fait du mal parce que c'est pas
en c'est pas en absorbant tout cette
négativité qu'on va pouvoir améliorer le
monde les gens qui améliore le monde
c'est certes sa plaque les
révolutionnaires ça peut
il ya eu beaucoup de violence dans notre
histoire dans l'histoire mondiale
parfois elle peut être nécessaire
malheureusement les mois je crois que
aujourd'hui et dans notre époque moderne
on peut on peut vivre les choses
autrement que je pense qu'il ya vraiment
une révolution là qui se passe
actuellement un progrès qu'on peut aller
vers et je pense que ça c'est grâce au
développement personnel je pense que la
petite échelle localement on peut on
peut faire bouger les choses et les
petits ruisseaux font les grandes
rivières ou peut pas on peut pas changer
le monde
individuellement mais en tout cas on
peut essayer de faire le bien autour de
soi en commençant déjà par s'améliorer
soi et améliorer les relations à voir
avec les autres petit à petit les choses
s'étendent et se propage et moi je crois
que tu vois ça je crois beaucoup au
local qui grandit niais qui va vers le
global je sais pas si je suis très très
très clair très très clair je travaille
moi mais la musique j'étais relativement
silencieux parce que justement ce que tu
dis est particulièrement clair et je
pense que je ne suis pas le seul
je pense que nos spectateurs lors ont
également remarqué c'est très clair et
effectivement ils sont cons et justement
sur youtube ou basse est un espace où on
a le choix de ce qu'on regarde de ce
qu'on consomme pour l'employé des mots
un peu un peu vulgaire mais qui
correspond à la situation aussi parce
que s'il consomme né dans le ventre ou
ceux consommés dans la tête ça relève là
aussi d'une démarche
voilà on choisit ce qu'on mange on
choisit ce qu'on regarde donc choisi ce
qu'on entend
on a cette possibilité là qui nous est
donnée aujourd'hui pouvoir choisir au
programme donc comme tu disais un esprit
qui se nourrit de choses positives à mon
avis s p qui entend prendre des choses
positives également et donc d'améliorer
le monde autour de soi
c'est vrai que quand à partir du moment
où on se réveille on b la radio ou les
les infos et qu'on a un tas
d'informations totalement oxygène qui
nous parviennent
ça donne juste envie de s'énerver de de
frapper 10,3 a vraiment de bonnes
dispositions pour améliorer les choses
on a cette possibilité de choisir c'est
bien le rappeler c'est un essentiel de
le rappeler tu avais parlé de cette
diète médiatique pour que l'excitation
est vraiment parfaite ça peut aussi
rejoindre les réseaux sociaux si parfois
peuvent être assez homogène
on a tout de suite envie de réagir à
tout ce qui me contrarie ça mobilise les
bases un jeu plein 10 ans ce qui va être
ce type de fonctionnement donc je pense
que c'est très salutaire de le leur
rappeler
et puisqu'on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien axel est ce que tu aurais un
dernier mois nous dire dernières
recommandations alors je précise par
dont 6 avant de laisser la parole où je
précise que pour ceux qui nous auraient
rejoint en cours de route
tu as un site internet laissant si le
lien est dans la description
tu as également créé une formation à
destination des personnes hypersensibles
qui s'appelle redis nous le titre est
lancée une formation pour les personnes
hypersensibles et anxieuse en société
voilà tu as l'impression d'avoir un
déficit estime que ce soit puisque c'est
le cas en général quand on est anxieux
en société ça s'appelle sérénité en
société voilà voilà ça il est temps
société donc vous trouvez là encore le
lien dans la description un extrait est
publié également sur la chaîne voudrait
facilement accès les sketches aux arrêts
et je vais le dire
pour terminer cette faute si l'un qui a
été extrêmement intéressant bah moi je
voulais juste remercier charles de me
permettre de m'exprimer
avec toi j'étais très heureuse de faire
ta connaissance j'ai beaucoup apprécié
mon travail donc j'ai été honorée d'être
contacté par toi vraiment un sens tout à
fait sincèrement et donc je remercie
aussi battait téléspectateurs enfin
spectateurs abonné aux malades de
m'écouter de m'avoir 1 je remercie ceux
qui pourront écouter jusqu'au bout parce
que je suis conscient que beaucoup
partir dans les digressions
c'est un peu des fois aussi et je pense
que beaucoup de gens aiment bien parce
que c'est dans les digressions qu'on
décroche un petit peu la rigueur la
rigidité que c'est là où les choses
peut-être les salles je pense me voilà à
apprécier moi je préfère je préfère être
sincère et à dire des choses comme je
pensais voilà toute façon il y aura des
gens qui le seront satisfaits avec sa
d'autres pas et m'attire en général les
personnes qui nous ressemble pas de
problème à me montrer fait que je suis
voilà je crois que c'est la meilleure
des choses à faire et c'est d'ailleurs
le message que je transmettrai apprenez
à vous connaître
apprenez à bien avec vous même et vous
serez bien avec les eaux voilà merci
beaucoup accède merci à trancher
[Musique]